I I just finished drinking the finest
wine
the the finest top tier wine because I
think I might have brought the wild of
wine yeah yeah I mean I think I might
have found like a game that's come into
like my new top 10 games of all time uh
because I just finished playing God of
War the new God of War oh and that is
it's it's like incredible yeah every
every sense of the words and I'm just
like [ __ ]
it's I I finished it like two days ago
and it's been a while since I've just
finished a video game I'm like I don't
know what to do with my life now
like I just feel an emptiness and I just
looked at like other because after
playing God of War I was just like I
wanted to play some other games and I
just looked through my game list and I
was like none of this is doing anything
for me I don't know one of this excites
me no no this excites me anymore how how
on Earth do I become a guitar again you
have the post no Clarity of games yeah
yeah yeah I don't know what to do
anymore I don't know you know what you
should do play Scotland
no that would that would just make it
worse because then I would just start
playing it I'm like this is this isn't
good no dude because you you'll you'll
understand the story is really good how
long is it and the music's really good
as long as the PS5 been out for
[Music]
I thought it was like two and a half
yeah I think it's like two and a half
years yeah I just realized I'm like I I
have I've had a PS5 and I've only gamed
on it like one time bro God of War I I
think you would really like it do I need
to play the previous yes you do see
that's the problem is I gotta go play
the old one I'm like oh have you played
anything no no no it's it's all like the
second one basically
um you have you played stuff like the
last of us or Uncharted or stuff like
that because it's kind of like in the
same kind of vein where it is like kind
of like a cinematic experience yeah
it looks really good yeah just I don't
know if I have the heart of me to go and
play the old one just to play the new
one well actually like the old one I
think the old one is [ __ ] fan is a
fantastic game by itself as well
um and by itself it's still a fantastic
game you're not losing anything by
playing the old one yeah the only thing
um like the old one Builds on these like
gameplay ideas and stuff like that and
one of the biggest criticisms of the old
one was there was just not enough
variation in one like the boss battles
and two enemy types
um and like and like kind of like the
gameplay itself and that's just because
with the first one they were completely
rebuilding the franchise from the ground
yeah so I actually really liked you know
the new like when they introduced like
new gameplays a bit slower a bit heavier
but
I think that's the perfect introduction
to this new game which takes all of the
ideas from this old game and then Builds
on everything basically so so when
playing the old one you'll get like the
freshness of like oh this feels good
this feels good and then just as it's
about to get boring then then you finish
the game and then you can go to the new
one where all these new ideas start
getting iterated and added on and right
yeah I think it's like the perfect
Journey as well from playing like the
first one to the second one because one
the story is amazing in both games
um and I'm surprised that they I'm
surprised they only did two games
because I expected it to be a Trilogy of
sorts but no it's it's after two games
the entire story arc is ended now so
it's the entire story arc of uh of the
Nordic gods or this this Nordic Arc per
se and yeah honestly one of the best
video game stories I've uh ever
experienced damn now you gotta finish
Alden rank so you can find out what game
of the year is this year yeah
okay here's the thing I even and even if
I finish Elder ring I don't think it
could be it's God of War for me because
you know you know me story story
important aspects of course there's
another story in Elden River
tell me the story you know them again
there's a ring of some kind I guess
because okay here's here's the thing uh
what playing God of War made me realize
and uh this is do you want to play a
movie huh does you wanna no no no no no
no no no I would play depth stranding
but that's actually the opposite
actually the opposite it made me realize
okay I actually do really care about
gameplay
but but like okay so let me let me break
this down right so there are some very
much Elden ring Souls like bosses in God
of War that are really really
challenging
um but you really have to it's like a
side quest right so it's not the main
quest story it's optional boss so the
hardest bosses in the game have nothing
to do with the mainline story right
that's good and and basically God of War
is one of those games that I enjoyed so
much that I wanted to complete like I
100 of the game which is only the second
game in my life that I've ever 100 which
just shows how much what's your first
one huh my first one is uh tails game
tells the symphony what the [ __ ] wait
you've never before that you'd never 100
of the game no I know what okay I'll
tell you oh I'll get to that I'll get to
that because what happened is I would
complete the story and I'm like okay
done well I don't need to play this game
anymore right you never thought wow this
game is fun I wonder if I should just do
the rest of the game no no that's that's
my point right because what I really
liked about God of War is that you can
do like one one thing side quest side
quests are [ __ ] incredible they
have as much impact into your emotions
and the story I feel like as much as
Mainline quest lines right that's that's
one thing that makes a really really
special game that's why everyone loves
The Witcher 3 and stuff like that God of
War has the same kind of philosophy
where you can do the mainline Quest but
the side quests are in my opinion just
as high quality as the mainline quests
so I wanted to do every single aspect of
this game
um and so by being really really high
quality it's a it tricked me into doing
the optional bosses right because
otherwise I would have no interest in
doing these optional hard bosses uh
because I'm like I'm here for the story
but because the quality of the story was
so high it tricked me into wanting to do
the optional bosses and in that process
I really really [ __ ] enjoyed my time
just challenging myself and just you
know doing like the whole Souls kind of
repeat Die Repeat die and after about 20
[ __ ] tries you finally to get that
Boston like that feels [ __ ] great
yeah I know I wouldn't have done that if
there wasn't a storyline to play through
right it's it's like I with gameplay in
order for me like you wanted to be
immersed in rather than just tacked on
at the end I need I need to know that
there's a payoff at the end right other
than just an intrinsic well isn't the
payoff the [ __ ] away so you just can't
you're like you play a game and you're
the only point of playing the game is so
that you know the ending's good yeah so
I know that so I know that I get
rewarded with something most of the time
isn't the payoff the fact that you 100
complete the game you like fighting
games right
I mean I mean I I do not like play a
game you're like oh this mechanics are
fun I want to keep playing this you're
like you're like I've got I hope this is
paying off soon I I'll find out I think
fighting games are different because I
think competitive games are different
because you get the satisfaction of
beating a human opponent right whereas
whereas in you know Souls like games
I've really really enjoy the bosses but
there's even though I feel really really
satisfied there's just there's always
this part missing where I want I want to
know I'm working towards something I
want to know I'm working towards a
storyline or you know I can't see or
self-improvement not a something you're
working towards is that not valuable
that's that's why that's why I could
never really get into competitive games
um well I mean like for like if I when I
played like Alden ring I'm like oh I
really enjoyed the aspect of
understanding the game mechanics and
getting better at doing it yeah I
enjoyed that I enjoyed getting better at
it so you necessarily care about what I
was getting I enjoyed that as well but
it's not core reason I would ever play a
game okay because I that I I can
appreciate it but it's kind of it's kind
of like you need you need to trick me
into okay getting me to care about it
you're gonna just get better at any kind
of thing that allows me better like it
would be something else there which is
why which is why I'm really I'm really
curious to see how you how you react to
God of War right because I think God of
War is like I've never seen such a
perfect marriage of gameplay and story
that blends so seamlessly God of War got
me to care about gameplay because it's
so seamlessly Blended in with the
combats
it Blended so seamlessly in with the
story that it actually got me to care
about the gameplay so there's a chance
that Conor might actually care about the
story I'm one I'm wondering if he could
do the impossible and get Connor to care
about the story because it got me to
care about the gameplay it got me to 100
in the game I [ __ ] love the gameplay
love the mechanics it got me to learn
like it's it's one of those gameplay
mechanics that's easy to pick up but
really really hard to master when you
get to like some of the really tougher
optional bosses and stuff like that
um and it got me to really care about
that which I would never usually spend
this many hours like learning learning
the mechanics of the gameplay um but I
did it because the story is amazing and
I wanted to grind through the story and
I wanted to experience as much of this
world and as much of these characters
um as I could that um Santa Monica
Studio have written and I've like built
up in this world I wanted to experience
and just spend more time with them and
that's why I wanted to grind through the
gameplay was because it was just such a
pleasure to spend time in this world and
the story I'm wondering if we could get
you to care about the story in the world
building
I heard a story very complicated
um first one is very simple and the
second one I heard was very like
complicated it's I I'm used to jrpg
stories
like simple app storage
you're like oh what do you mean you
didn't read the full Wikipedia page
before starting this Arc and it's like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I'm not
gonna go out and Google [ __ ] yeah just
let me play the game like if I got I
want to watch Connor play 13th centers
the game requires you to like study
outside of the game or read [ __ ] outside
of the game then I think it's failed as
a game oh no like a story it's it's not
in fact I've way preferred the second
game because the story had the story was
a bit more complicated there were a lot
more aspects Connor you forget God's a
fate fan yeah
it's not even it's not even complicated
I don't think it's it's like
I'm just think I'm just thinking because
like the first the first game was about
as simple as you can get okay let me let
me tell you the story of the first game
okay so so Kratos is a dad in this one
he has a wife his wife dies and his wife
says please spread my ashes on the
highest peak on the Realms and the first
game is them going to the highest realm
I've been spreading her ashes and that's
that's the game that's right that's how
yeah I like that yeah that's that's easy
easy second game
um it's about time travel comes in
multiple Dimensions so there's Kratos
blue yeah
Super Saiyan Kratos yeah the second game
is more about well they don't want
Kratos doesn't want to go to war because
he's even though he's the God of War he
doesn't really want to go to war and
then inevitably they find uh he ends up
going to war yeah that's a very
simplified version of the events but
that's basically what happens
they needed to find a reason for
conflict to happen and that's why I
think the second game is a bit more a
bit more like has more moving Parts but
at the end of the day it's compared to
like some other movies or some other
stories I mean I I think the [ __ ] MCU
is more complicated than game uh than
the God of War so it's it's not a
complicated the MCU is not complicated
out of design it's complicated because
they're trying to milk it and then yeah
it's getting out of hand yeah and also
it's [ __ ] yeah like if you can follow
[ __ ] like Game of Thrones or most I mean
most TV shows God of War is not that
complicated at all it can be if you like
go into like the lawn like the World
building and everything like that but in
terms like the the core story it's it's
fine it's fine your monkey brain can
follow along don't worry about it